we are learning new details about a man
accused of killing a boy whose body was
found in a freezer and the lengths he
went to to keep the mother of that child
from the outside world victoria saha
joins us now after hearing from her
lawyer
denise the lawyer four-wheeled mason
dominguez's mom says she has officially
been ruled out as a suspect though
police have not confirmed that or stated
she was a suspect now her lawyer gives
us a look at what she went through in
the hands of her boyfriend 35-year-old
brandon toastland in the months before
mason's body was discovered
brandon toslin is described as a monster
according to the lawyer of mason's mom
in march of 2021 the two start dating
and move in together two months after
her husband died her lawyer tells me
their relationship was very blissful in
the beginning according to her lawyer
tozlin slowly started to control the
family until they were trapped december
11th is when mason's mom says she last
saw him her lawyer also says she
realized she was being captive when
toslin locked her in a room starting the
months-long captivity her lawyer claims
toslin had locks and window alarms
throughout the house and took control of
her social media accounts according to
her lawyer toslin also pretended to be
mason's mom and cut off all ties with
her job and family during captivity the
family was locked in separate rooms the
mother going through abuse in the hands
of toastland and her kids also going
through the same ordeal her lawyer also
says during school drop-offs for her
seven-year-old toastland would park far
away from school grounds and put sun
shades in the windshield and handcuffed
the mom while he walked her daughter
into school police say the mom started
questioning toastland about where mason
was one day he told her he died but
would not let her see his body her
lawyer tells me tolseland repeatedly
threatened the mom with guns in the
house and kept saying quote there are
unsolved murders every day they will not
get me if they can't find a body
it was while she was in the car she was
able to write small notes over the
course of a few weeks on tuesday those
notes were handed to her daughter who
gave them to a teacher which led police
to the house where they found mason's
body in a freezer ryan victoria thank
you for that one